la Unión Europea pone sobre la mesa la
propuesta de un décimo paquete de
sanciones lo propone a las capitales
europeas con el objetivo de que para la
semana que viene ya esté aprobado este
nuevo paquete de sanciones coincidiendo
con el primer aniversario desde que
empezó la invasión de Ucrania en este
décimo paquete la Unión Europea está
interesada sobre todo en aumentar la
prohibición a la exportación de
componentes tecnológicos la presidenta
de la comisión europea Úrsula fonder
Legend ha cifrado en un total de 11.000
millones de euros el impacto de estas
nuevas sanciones para Rusia además
también propone sancionar a empresas
iraníes vinculadas a la guardia
Revolucionaria de Irán sobre todo que
fabriquen drones que luego son enviados
a Ucrania para bombardear al país
también se amplía la lista de entidades
y de personas que sean sancionadas por
la Unión Europea ampliandola así a más
de Hay personas en total la Unión
Europea insiste en que estas sanciones
todos los paquetes están funcionando y
que de hecho están teniendo un impacto
en la economía rusa a pesar de que el
fondo monetario internacional prevé un
crecimiento para Rusia para este año el
jefe de la diplomacia europea Joseph
asegura que las sanciones son como un
veneno su acción es lenta pero las
consecuencias irreversibles y pone como
ejemplo la cuestión de los componentes
tecnológicos de la que Rusia
especialmente es muy dependiente de
Europa la Unión Europea está decidida a
mostrar en los últimos días en que las
acciones que se han tomado contra Rusia
están siendo determinantes para
presionar al régimen de Vladimir Putin y
que la presión va a seguir el tiempo que
sea necesario